en su primer día de Presidencia del
Consejo de la Unión Europea Pedro
Sánchez El jefe de gobierno español optó
por visitar kiev durante el simbólico
encuentro con el presidente ucraniano
Polo dimir zelemski Sánchez reiteró El
compromiso del bloque europeo de apoyar
el lado ucraniano por el tiempo que sea
necesario así como la candidatura de
Ucrania para unirse a los 27
la comisión europea ha emitido
recientemente una evaluación provisional
sobre el estado de la candidatura de
Ucrania para adherirse a la Unión
Europea el informe es positivo y muestra
Progreso significativos
Si bien el líder español también se
comprometió a entregar a kiev más
material militar y fondos de 55 millones
de euros para la reconstrucción
zellensky mostró su desencanto por la
ralentización en la entrega del
reglamento por parte de algunos aliados
y expresó frustración por la falta de un
cronograma claro para entrenar pilotos
ucranianos en el manejo de aviones de
combate estadounidenses f-16 reclamando
también su entrada en la otan
solo puedo insistir una vez más en que
necesitamos una señal muy clara y
comprensible en la Cumbre de vilna de
que Ucrania puede convertirse en un
miembro de la otan en igualdad de
condiciones después de la Guerra
el presidente ucraniano Espera que con
la llegada de Sánchez a la presidencia
europea kiev hacer que posturas con
América Latina Ucrania trabaja con sus
aliados para generar una amplia apoyo
internacional con el fin de lograr una
paz sin concesiones territoriales para
Rusia